Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie. So Rick and Morty has a whole bunch of theories, a whole bunch of secrets
I'm gonna be explaining the biggest one, and a big season three update.
So here we go.
There is a new round of the giveaway going
on now too. All you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
Be sure to click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything.
There are a lot of secrets about Rick and
Morty, some of them funnier than others but
the biggest is that there is a highly serialized
storyline that's running in the background
that they call like the secret storyline that you only
get inklings of in the first two seasons that
they'll also continue to tease out in season
three and that is, is that not every episode
follows the same Rick and Morty.
Rick has a dimension portal gun so he goes
to different dimensions in every episode
but on top of that, because there are infinite
Ricks, like we have the Council of Ricks which
I'll talk about in a second, the episodes
are not necessarily following the same Rick
and Morty every single week.
The two best examples of that are the season
two episodes "Morty Night Run" and "Total Rickall".
I don't know how this works!
Help me!
What the hell?
I know, right?
So "Morty Night Run" shows you the interdimensional
Jerry daycare where they mix up Jerry's at
the end of the episode and Rick can't remember
which Jerry from which universe belongs to
him so he kinda just roll the dice and says
"Eh, I don't care that much.
Whatever, let's go."
Hey, Morty, there's our Jerry.
I missed you. Hey, Rick.
Glad you're safe, Jerry. What do you say we go home?
I'd like that.
Hey, wait, uh, do you have 5126?
Uh, I'm not sure. Morty?
Uhh, that's a Blips and Chitz ticket.
What?!
Psh, way to go, Morty. Eh, whatever.
Uh, w-wait...what?
Alright, c'mon, Jerry!
So on one level the moment's just meant to
be really funny, make you question your sanity...
Wait a minute, is 5126
Rick and Morty the people we started the episode
with, or is it this other Rick and Morty? Or
is it like another version? So you just spiral
out of control. And if you were wondering, the
Rick and Morty that we typically follow in
each episode is C - 137 dimension
Rick and Morty but on another level, it's
meant to poke fun at how TV shows are really
bad at keeping their own continuity. Doctor
Who is a TV show that's notorious for breaking
its own continuity, but the brilliant thing
that I think that Dan Harmon, Ryan Ridley, Justin
Roiland and have done, is embrace this chaos
and just write it into the show.
Yet, maybe we don't leave the episode with the
same Rick and Morty as we did at the beginning
of the episode.
Speaking of episodes that make you question
your sanity.
The next best example that we're not following
the same Rick and Morty every single week
is "Total Rickall", an episode that aired a couple
weeks after this first example.
Is anyone here even real? Am I the only real person on Earth?!
Maybe. Or maybe, just maybe, we're all real.
You know me, I'm Reverse Giraffe. I have a short neck and legs.
I went to college with Hamurai.
I saved Ghost in a Jar's life in Vietnam.
And Beth, how many times have I been a shoulder
for you to cry on?
Ah, too many.
Okay, so maybe, we're just all fake!
"Total Rickall" is one of my favorite
episodes for a number of reasons, but Mr.
Poopy Butthole, this character here, if you're
not familiar with him that's actually his
name.
He says he's been living with the family for
this whole time.
But they find out that there are mental parasites
living off of them and they can't trust what
all the new characters that continually pop
up say. Eventually they figure out that the
parasites are only capable of generating happy
memories.
So if they have terrible memories of someone,
like Summer beating Morty, then we know that
Summer is real.
Oh oh oh really? Well I remember you as a whiny little piece of shit, Morty!
Oh-oh yeah?
Yeah! I've got about a thousand memories of your dumb little ass
and about six of them are pleasant!
The rest is annoying garbage.
So why don't you do us both a favor, and pull the trigger?!
Do it! Do it, motherf*cker!
Pull the f*cking trigger!
Oh, wow. Baby Wizard was a parasite?
He set me up with my wife!
What the hell?
I figured it out, Rick!
The parasites can only create pleasant memories.
I know you're real because I have a ton of bad
memories with you.
So eventually it comes down
to Mr. Poopy Butthole and Beth cannot remember
anything bad about him.
So thinking that he's a parasite shoots him
but he turns out to be real and that means
that he's been telling the truth this whole
time. He's been with the family.
They even added him to the credits, the opening
credits of the episode.
Just to make you feel like he's been with
this family for all of these seasons just
taken in the context of this episode that
was really them just messing with the audience
a little bit like "Hey, see, he's been here this
whole time.
This is going to be a really funny joke." But,
it actually fits into the continuity of the
show and that's one of the other big secrets
about the show itself.
So just further evidence that we don't always
follow the same Rick and Morty from the same
dimension every single time because there
is a Mr. Poopy Butthole that's lived with the
family for the whole time in a dimension but
like during season one we don't visit his
dimension at all, there are infinite dimensions,
so that even means that if we see Mr. Poopy
Butthole come back during season three that
it could be a completely different version
of the character.
Don't fall asleep!
Is this what bleeding to death is? Oh-wee. Is this how I die?
Aw jeez! Oh my god.
Why would you do this, Beth?
It's not supposed to hurt I-I thought. Hoo-wee.
The
other big secret about this which I think
is a little bit funnier is that in making
the show they try to say you know "Reddit-proof" it.
It just like people that picked through look
for details find things they try to add a
lot of that in the background just to make it
a lot more fun for the audience, so in season
one, for example.
They didn't really have the idea about following
different Rick and Morty's in different dimensions
until they got to season two, so the show
changes a little bit each season.
They mess with the continuity, but they do
try to make it all work together.
Jeez, Rick. W-what is this place?
The Citadel of Ricks. It's the secret headquarters for the Council of Ricks.
Council of Ricks?
As you know Morty I've got a lot of enemies in the universe
that consider my genius a threat.
Galactic terrorists, a few sub-galactic dictators, most of the entire intergalactic government. Wherever
you find people with heads up their asses,
someone wants a piece of your grandpa.
One of the best examples
of this early on in season one when they were
still kind of figuring the show out was when
they visited the Council of Ricks which is
actually based on the comic book Council of
Reeds, a bunch of Reed Richards banding together
from different universes, different realities
and working together so it gives you a taste
for the idea that there are infinite
Ricks out there, but it kind of breaks the
season two theory that we're not following the same
Rick and Morty, just because new episodes
tend to start with Rick and Mortys with the
same haircuts that almost looked identical
and way back in season one when they're visiting
the Council of Ricks before they had this
all figured out. On the left here, this is Rick
Prime.
Meaning that he is the first Rick.
So now recontextualize with what's going on
in season two, not following the same Rick
and Morty, you wonder what happened to that
first Rick and who is the Rick that we started
with at the beginning of season one? Well the
answer for that at the end of season two is
this Rick right here. He's supposed to be the
first
Rick and when they wrote the Council of Ricks
it was just intended to be this big mind trip
but now we come to season three and they'll
probably expand on that even more. Like, hey
maybe, maybe something else is going on here.
So there are a number of secret storylines, and
I'll do more bonus videos for each of them.
The other really big one is the story of the
Galactic government pursuing all of the Ricks
in all of the dimensions creating the need for
the Council of Rick's to be created.
So unless they drop an actual season three
trailer, that will probably be my next Rick
and Morty bonus video.
Feel free to recommend videos in the comments
like Mr. Poopy Butthole is the most powerful
character on Rick and Morty because he knows
that he's inside a TV show.
-you think of that finale, huh? Mmm. You think t-the Smith family's gonna be o-kaaay?
Yeah, I don't know what you're talking about, bro. Your total is $12.37.
Woo-wee! You think Rick's gonna get out of jail?
Woo-wee! You think the family's gonna rescue him?
Ha ha! Oh, wo wee! Ooh wee! Ow!
Tune in to Rick and Morty season three in like, a year and a half, or longer
to see how we unravel this mess! Ooh-wee!
There's a theory that Rick understands
he's inside a TV show and I know a lot of
you have asked for Easter egg videos but because
there's so many I could do videos for every
single episode that's happened so far, so I haven't
quite figured out the best way to accomplish that.
So bonus videos will probably start off of
the really big concepts and then I might do
some more specific episode videos, but you
guys can just let me know what you want.
So season three, just to give an update, recently
they came out and said that there's probably
no way I mean it's really too late now for
it to air December originally.
that was the plan.
But now, it sounds like it might not even
air till March, but no one has officially
confirmed that. Adult Swim is pretty notorious
for just kind of waiting till they're getting
ready to air and then just dropping stuff,
so really what I'm expecting is, is that when
we get a little bit closer, the creators will
actually start talking about it like "Yeah we're
probably gonna be airing in the next month
or two but the big holdup has been the animation."
Like at the end of the summer,
that was the reason why they had to readjust
their air date.
So originally December, now closer to March
of next year, which is okay, because there will be 14
episodes, so will probably happen is is will
see that trailer sometime in January maybe February.
Usually it's at least a month out from whenever
the series airs,
is when TV show start really dropping
new footage so I will say congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner, Super Bob, you
win a $20 Amazon gift card, be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details. You can blow
it on Christmas loot, or whatever you want.
So I've already started a new round in this video,
I'll announce the winner when I post that
next Rick and Morty video.
So get hype, Star Wars Easter eggs coming later
tonight, so make sure you go see Rogue One.
There are a ton of Easter eggs for the other
series as well as like unused stuff the George
Lucas did not include in the original films.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my non-spoiler-y Rogue One review
and you can click here for the trailer for
the next episode of The Flash. Thank you so
much for watching everybody, let's high five, I'll
see you guys tonight!